As we previously discussed, the Unreal Engine's reflection system does some of the memory
management for us, however we should have a deeper dive into the garbage collector.
As mentioned earlier, data is marked for memory management using the reflection macros.
For instance, for a member variable to be managed, it must be marked up with UProperty.
Unreal keeps a root set of UObjects, acting as a base for the garbage collector's
iterative searches, and we'll touch on how it uses that root set in just a second.
Many objects can be added to the root set, and actors can be explicitly destroyed, removing
them from the root set and allowing them to be GC'd.
This will also mean that their components can be GC'd as well, as their link to that
root set has been broken.
Once GC starts, Unreal proceeds through the following steps to find what needs collecting.
We can see in Figure 1, when the garbage collector kicks in, all UObjects are marked
as unreachable from the root set.
At this point, all objects are considered viable for garbage collection.
We need to process all references to see if anything truly is unreachable.
We can see in Figure 2, Unreal builds a reference tree, breaking down how one object is linked
to another.
We can see that we've got a single tree from the root set with two branches.
In this case, we can see that nothing is left truly unreachable, and none of the
objects will be viable for garbage collection.
If the UObject is still unreachable once we've iterated over all of the objects, we can
commence collecting that object.
Moving on to Figure 3, we can see that if we were to break the reference between Object
1 and Object 3, we can see that the Object 3 to Object 4 branch is now unreachable in
its entirety, and will be appropriately garbage collected.
We discussed earlier, when talking about reflection macros, how the use of UClass gives
us access to all UFunction and UProperty specifiers, allowing Unreal to manage the memory for
us.
However, we may want to keep a reference to a reflected type inside of a regular class.
As that class isn't a reflected type itself, it will not show up in that initial reference
tree, and any members inside will be unreachable.
We can solve this by extending our class from the FGCObject class, and implementing
its AddReferencedObject or AddReferencedObjects functions.
The members added to the FReferenceCollector will be managed as if they have been marked
up by a UProperty specifier.
As long as the GCObject remains in existence, the UObjects within it will remain referenced.
When working with the garbage collector as engineers and developers, there's a few things
we really should keep in mind.
UObject manipulation isn't thread safe.
It's highly recommended that UObjects are accessed from the game thread.
In cases where we want access on other threads, proper use of synchronization primitives
are required to avoid common parallel programming errors, and be cautious as this could
result in a loss of performance.
The garbage collector cannot see raw pointers inside UObjects, so always use reflective
properties or smart pointers when possible.
An object can be marked as pending kill, meaning the developer wants the object to
be garbage collected even if it is still referenced.
This will not cause the immediate destruction.
It merely indicates to the garbage collector that this object should be considered for
cleanup next time the garbage collector is triggered.
The Unreal Engine offers C++ programmers a smart pointer library, which is Epic's
own flavor of C++ smart pointers.
It's important to know that Unreal smart pointers are for non-UObjects, because as
we discussed in the previous slides, reflected types are handled by a different memory tracking
system, with the exception of the TWig object pointer.
These T-pointers and T-refs are platform-agnostic versions of the standard C++ smart pointers,
and have been designed to behave similarly to their C++ counterparts.
These pointers allow us to manage the lifespan of non-reflected types with knowledge
that they'll be cleaned up safely when all the references have been removed.
Aside from the C++-based smart pointers, we also have access to TWig object pointers.
This smart pointer is unique in that it is purely for reflected types.
A TWig object pointer behaves exactly as a standard library's Wig pointer does.
It will not keep the object alive or kept away from the garbage collector.
A TWig object pointer can be assessed for validity without accessing the pointer itself,
which is very, very useful when working with a lambda-heavy codebase.
Smart pointers provide a number of benefits to the Unreal programmer.
They help prevent memory leaks, as the memory is released as soon as the inner pointer is
no longer referenced anywhere.
They can be thread-safe, with the caveat that the thread-safe versions are slower
than the non-thread-safe versions because of the atomic reference counting.
And they also provide a great deal of runtime safety, in that a T-shared ref cannot
be null, and it can be dereferenced safely.
T-shared and the shared pointer inside the standard library are the same size under the
hood.
However, we'd opt for Unreal's flavor of shared pointer for its platform agnosticism.
Objects don't intrinsically know that they're wrapped in a T-shared pointer, so Unreal
presents a solution, the T-shared from this class.
Inheriting from T-shared from this with a template allows us to grab a T-shared ref
to the class using the following functions, the as-shared and shared this functions.
It should be noted that whilst Unreal smart pointers are a fantastic tool for developers,
they do not come for free.
They do incur a small performance cost when passing them around, and as such it's advisable
that the underlying pointer is passed around as a const ref instead.